wohin geht die reise mit con crafter ich
habe ich sage es ist einfach mal leute
was geht hier vor kran ii und heute gibt
es ein kleines jump league video mit ein
paar fragen
gegen 15 uhr und ich finde dann extra
für dieses video der gestern und
vorgestern schon 1 kam
sorry dafür übrigens vorgestern ax daran
dass sie kenne ich lust hat im video
aufzunehmen gestern gab es noch relativ
wichtigen termin den ich war nie musste
vielleicht verlieren idee man weiß es
nicht
auf jeden fall heute ein paar fragen ich
bin extra wie gesagt von diesen kleinen
festival open air teil zurückgefahren
habe ich dieses video aufnehmen kann
ich hoffe ihr wisst das zu schätzen und
dann legen immer los so was ist zurzeit
ein lieblingslied mit hashtag grashalm
habe ich mir übrigens wagen stehen
lassen
mein aktuelles lieblingslied also ich
weiß ich hab das schon gesagt dass ich
ein so genaues lieblings habe ich finde
stelle tintin ist sein job finde ich
ganz gut von harry potter voll unbekannt
so dass dieser ganze indie sound platt
rap was soll ich noch gerne dran ist
supercool und ja sonst gibt es auch noch
die ein oder andere sache die ich gerne
höre sie laufen können wir auch so durch
hier bist du auf der gamescom und
trinkst du wieder auf der gamescom bin
ich denke ich mal nicht sondern nur bei
den video days ist also sehr parallel
vielleicht schaue ich mal für ein zwei
stündchen rüber zur gamescom
aber ich denke mal ich bin eher bei den
video days war ich da auch davon ausgeht
dass da mehr leute von euch sind ja
so fliegen bahn oder auto
interessante frage also ich finde am
coolsten eigentlich bahnfahren klar
deutsche bands oft unendlich unpünktlich
und die die bedingungen mit dem man
daraus sind auch nicht immer so die
coolsten sagen immer ausgefallener
klimaanlage oder sonst was aber es ist
schon am entspanntesten autofahren macht
auch spaß ich habe jetzt ein paar wochen
meinen führerschein und darf alleine
fahren zudem schon 18
aber ich würde sagen am entspanntesten s
bahn fahren wenn du halt wirklich wenn
es so ist wie es sein sollte das heißt
dass du internet hass und so weiter dann
ist das schon ganz cool wie dann kennst
du luca schon und existiert als mobil
nach ich kenne luca stimmt schon sechs
jahre oder so was also noch deutlich vor
youtube auch bevor er sich seinen kanal
gemacht hat glaube ich sogar und ob es
mobile noch existiert habe lukas dad
hatte damit geschmückt gedanken gespielt
ist zu vernichten wir aber nicht kannst
dich ja ansonsten wird natürlich direkt
maus mobile 2.0 gebaut und das keine
störgeräusche gibt wer ist der nächste
gegner bei community crash das weiß ich
noch gar nicht
aber ich habe mich auf jeden fall
entschieden dass sich community clash
auf während war noch weiterführen sollte
natürlich vorausgesetzt dass sich in war
überhaupt überleben
dass er hier können kein spyder sein
oder sonstiges und man weiß es halt
wirklich nie bei warum aber community
patch wird definitiv fortgesetzt auf
jeden fall so gut dann warum hält der
gras haben und glaubst du dass waro drei
weiter gedacht dass ich da weiter
vormals ein paar o2 ich hoffe es mal ich
weiß natürlich schon aber ich hoffe also
dass eure sich kann ich nur sagen ich
hoffe mal dass ich weiter kommen werde
weil war o2 bin ich halt in der ersten
folge gestorben und
ganz so unwahrscheinlich ist ja auch
nicht dass ich da weiterkommen
aber wie gesagt noch spyder
ich habe jetzt einfach mal aus eurer
position geredet dass es nicht
unwahrscheinlich ist und was und damit
jetzt nichts vor ausgenommen
was sind für gras also die ganzen
unanständigen leute die denken ich würde
hier von mit diesem komischen gras reden
was ist auch noch gibt ich rede
natürlich von normalen grashalmen
bestätigt auch wirklich lustig und
verstehe ich auch nicht so so welches
ist das ist jetzt dein schönstes
erlebnis
solche sie fragen
schönstes irgendwas es unglaublich
schwer zu beantworten es gibt so viele
schöne momente und man hat vielleicht
nicht immer alle vor augen und dann wird
man das fleisch das falsche sagen
daher weiß ich nicht mehr seine
lieblingsbeschäftigung im sommer das
mache ich am liebsten im sommer also ich
bin als super gerne am meer und sowas
ist klar aber ich bin auch also ich bin
auch gerne einfach in kühlen räumen und
will das auch wirklich gut finde ich so
wenn man die arbeiten muss wenn man die
ganze zeit in der hitze ist und dann
einfach zum kühlen raum weit kommt ist
wunderschöne peinlichstes erlebnis
beantwortet dass diese ultimativen
fragen dass ich da nicht immer eine
antwort auf was war das an strengste
beziehungsweise nervigste alter leute
ihr wisst dass doch ich mache doch
nichts erstmals im juni dass ich da das
mich schwer tue da solche fragen zu
beantworten
aber okay ich habe mich trotzdem von
hier oben springen falls von unten
schaffte erst recht nicht welche
youtuber guckst in deiner freizeit meine
videos macht auf jeden zweiten tag
ungefähr 1 juni auch ewig weiter sprung
aber welches den lieblingstieren von
welchem tier hast du angst mein
lieblingstier keine ahnung
ein bisschen angst hatte ich verbunden
weil ich halt mal gebissen wurde
aber deshalb mehr so heißen die
instinktiv dass sie da dass ich ein
bisschen schiss habe vorrunden paket
alter das soll nicht weiter dass ich da
ein bisschen schiss vor habe aber wenn
du mich auf 100 ein bisschen einlasse
also auch von freunden freundin sonst
was dann ist das oftmals auch kein
größeres problem habe ich ein tolles
bild werden ritter als profilbild schon
ziemlich cool auf jeden fall
bist du glücklich was machst was macht
ein glückliches leben für dich aus ein
glückliches leben macht für mich aus
dass man zu also zufrieden natürlich
seine zufriedenheit und glück ist
relativ nah beieinander heißt gutes
sozialleben ist auch immer für sich
wirtschaftlich nicht übermäßig schlecht
geht und so was jetzt komplett
irgendwie habe ich da keine probleme mit
dem modul wohin geht die reise mit
konkreter ich glaube sie ist einfach mal
und zwar reisen wir beide nach wales für
mich sicher ob man das da ob wir das
schon sagen dürfen man das geht doch
nicht dieser dreck sprung
wir reisen nach wales luca und ich
vielleicht kommen noch jemand drittes
mit wir sehen uns aber noch nicht ganz
sicher aber es wird definitiv in kraft
hatte kassel roadtrips und wir haben ein
heftiges programm schon was wir alles
machen werden
darauf könnt ihr freund davon werden
natürlich die loks kommen es geht es
geht wirklich nicht gerade ganz an der
kante abgesprungen und spaß irgendwas
mach ich doch falsch da muss irgendwo an
der seite eine leiter sein oder so fich
durch meine weil es ihr nichts passieren
werde
magst du bist ein jockey an die zt
lecken ja und ich hoffe dass er jetzt so
oft bei warum machen kann
die ferien smogs du erst als könnte man
dein bruder in der pfeife rauchen weiß
nicht wovon die leute hier reden keine
ahnung ist das video zu ende was wir
fragen
mann ich bin oft unkonzentriert
das musste sein jetzt bin wirklich
unkonzentriert gerade wie gesagt draußen
sind 30 grad oder sowas und wir haben
uns schon das ein oder andere glas milch
gewinnt und ich bin es wirklich nur für
video zurückgekommen von daher sehen wir
dass nach ich habe auf jeden fall gut es
geht nicht verdammt noch mal ich habe
guten willen gezeigt weil ich gerade
sagen jetzt beruhigt mich wieder wie
lange hänge ich schon an diesem dreck
spart wo er die andere leute sind auch
vorbei alter das muss gehen und
natürlich jeder pacult geht irgendwo
aber das ist doch wirklich diese einen
sprung vor einem bis dahin ist alles so
leicht und ist heute glücklich dass man
das jetzt so aussieht man nein alles
cool beruhigt ich mag es so weißt du
schon wieder ein leben weitergehen soll
als ob du studierst du was du gerne
später arbeiten möchtest ok endlich ist
was möchte ich gerne arbeiten das weiß
ich noch nicht so genau aber ich habe ja
schon eine grobe idee also irgendwie so
medien mäßig auf jeden fall etwas ok
erstmal abbauen damit die sich hier
gläschen werden und dann kann ich
vielleicht
abstauben beleben hat in dieser mensch
bitte wo mein gott
dave ist auch relativ lau seien habe
jetzt einen relativ günstigen sportler
response punkt gehabt ich weiß auch
nicht so schlecht geht direkt auf jeden
fall ja schon wieder der andere tut
da haben wir erst mal im kopf haben
sondern diese erst mal kämpfen und ich
halte mich jetzt erstmal zurück warum
fieser hash der portugiese hashtag
schreiber so fies ist ja der steckt
grasheim gar nicht hinter sogar relativ
fröhlich so bist du real ich bin sowas
von real leute glauben das nicht
also ich bin definitiv real leute meinen
ich bin so kacke gerade ich bin echt
nicht so ganz beisammen
tut mir leid leute welche länder
beziehungsweise städte möchtest du noch
gerne bereisen also wales auf jeden fall
luzern
das wird unglaublich cool wales ist
einfach so ein land das ist nicht so ein
typisches turi land und das hat richtig
schöne landschaften glaube ich und wir
werden einfach rum fahren und uns
einfach können und das wird einfach mega
cool werden
von daher habe ich übertrieben spock
darauf denkst du dass du jetzt
qualitativ bessere videos macht als also
besser content als im ersten jahr deiner
youtube karriere im ersten jahr war ich
glaube ich noch relativ unsicher und so
konnten mäßig bin ich immer noch nicht
so und ab also ich mache halt mehr so
meine
geht man gaming videos so was ja relativ
easy ist und so was aber ein bisschen
habe ich mich definitiv gesteigert würde
ich sagen wollt ihr denn
hatte wie einfach alle auf mich gehen
irgendwie so gefühlt machte geht jetzt
auch wieder auf nicht aber desktop-suche
die müssen auch so sein aber ich hab nur
noch ein herz für kinder
wenn ich erst mal lieber und hoffe dass
die beiden sich auch mal bekriegen
ich habe auch nur noch so wenig essen
eigentlich habe ich gar nicht so viele
möglichkeiten ist der hashtag einer okay
richtig lustig wenn du können lust mehr
auf youtube passt kannst du dir
vorstellen zum fernsehen zu gehen also
wie ich gesagt habe medien sind relativ
cool aber ich glaube fernsehen ist dann
halt doch noch mal was komplett anderes
als youtube.com irgendwie vergessen
hier kann ich ihnen zum fair spielerin
hat nicht mal mehr zeit zu lesen
ja leute ich bin schlecht hier verloren
die wünsche reagieren wir das sind sie
community crash wieder absetzt das kommt
nicht voran
doch dann will ich einfach freundlich
darum bitten dass ich wieder rein machen
und dann wird es gehen denke ich mal
ja leute das war's von heute ich war ein
bisschen fällig und hat vielleicht ein
bisschen milch in meinem brain aber das
war es von mir jetzt geht es wieder
zurück zum festival
ich hoffe dieser kleiner einschub hat
euch gefallen wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder macht's gut
da wollte ich bin kein tschüss